[Music]
hi everyone I am Jennifer Shahani and
the resident teacher here at the club
for last week and this week and I'm
gonna be reading unfortunately on Friday
but it's been my pleasure to give
lectures this one is kind of a
continuation of what I did last lecture
since many of the same students attend
both we talked about a Pillsbury game
and if you're watching on YouTube you
might want to check that lecture out
first and we also talked a little bit
about the Queen within across the street
at the world chess Hall of Fame and the
relationship between beauty and art in
clothing and beauty in chess and I was
talking about this dress which is really
one of the highlight pieces across the
street it's a victor in wolf's dress
there's a Katy Perry wore it and it's
you know absolutely like stunning when
you go to the exhibit this is an
installation photo actually and what I
was saying was that the fact is it's
amazing that the dress looks relatively
simple and yet somehow it also has these
holes in it and it's completely perfect
otherwise and how in chess problems
there is a theory that if there's
extraneous things in the position that
don't have anything to do with the
solution like just some pawns or Brooks
or something random that could easily be
taken off it's an inferior problem right
so that that reminded me of the idea
that if there was extra things inside
this dress that would be inferior it
wouldn't be as as beautiful even if you
couldn't see it right away now let's
take a look at one position that I've
always kind of liked well I've liked it
since I've seen it which is generally
the idea with studies and problems last
time we went over one of the most
beautiful simple positions I think in
chess the famous ready pawning and here
we've got something that's a little bit
more complicated but it's still very few
pieces on the board and so you can
imagine it coming from a real game
although it's certainly a little bit
otter because how did this this rook get
here exactly
but that's not where we're looking at
we're not looking at retrograde analysis
as as they call it we're just looking
for the best move here for white so I'll
wait to move and win not yet I do it
this is this is like so cool I want to
get people a chance to see it definitely
longer than a few seconds
you want to write it down or something
Julian make sure you have it you can
write it down yeah no not don't help him
here here's like an old score sheet in
some time write down if you want so
pretty hard I mean this is unless you've
seen it before it's like pretty tough to
find this instantly I'd say especially
all the variations there's a couple but
there's a couple nines
I know a lot of people want to try work
takes rock and then after King cakes
you want to try to work out one check
and then after King to g8 ke7 thready
okay wait Lily let's let's form a
consensus I see you're on okay so what
do we want to play King g7 or do we want
to play chess what I've heard both from
those exactly exactly and that's not in
the that's not winning because obviously
this pawn and that's that's an example
like these pieces are needed right
because otherwise if you don't have
these pieces on the board otherwise you
could just do something like this and be
winning right so it's important to have
something in the board so instead you
want to play checks okay and sorry
instead of teeny 7 right now if I think
okay so what's your threat is running
you what your training work to you 1
followed by king f7 is that what you're
saying okay so what do you think I play
is black well if B if I play B to here
then you're just gonna follow through
with your plan right and after we rook
to you one Jack King H a king here yeah
you can't stop me well if Kim g7
sorry if King g7 same thing right yeah
that's the problem
so if h5o keep between things in the
wrong order if H five now if works you
uncheck here here it's not me right
cuz looking black light now black can
play h6 and now this is not made to try
so
we can look like let's say so I think
it's so you're saying you want to just
try to like pick up the pawns but I mean
no you work first night with those pawns
should be a draw unless you have like a
meet or something right so Shawn's
wondering but just playing work over
here and trying to pick up this pawn and
see but you know I mean it should be
okay for black we can't hold on to the
pawn unfortunately but we can just play
here you know and see why those should
be winning these two bronze right so
instead that might give you some ideas
of that whole variation that's the thing
about chess and problems especially but
even like a regular checkmating attack
when you look at incorrect variations a
lot of the time they hold within them
the solution right do you really have it
we're going to think a little longer
not g7 no it doesn't it doesn't doesn't
white court doesn't quite do it
[Music]
if 4kj work takes a date and then what
work what Brooke Effie it hit f1 and
then where's Black House ago I know what
you like too then I have eight six
I am pond 8x uh-huh move order exactly
and this is why even though these things
people complain that they're impractical
that studies and problems never occur in
real games I mean these are exactly the
types of variations and ideas that we
need to improve on move order all right
Julian called it out over kh8 rook takes
h8 well because now we're of course
friend named work 2f lon right because
that's also be to just lead to mate
after work F lon so kind of has to take
and now we play work F 1 check 14 Kings
y8 and instead of King g7 which allows 8
sex which kind of saw before we play
eight six and this is just a fabulous
move right I mean just shutting
everything and inside and now after
after takes an age six now white plays
canny salmon and it is actually forced
mate right we're playing worked in do
you want and there's there's no way
there's no way out so pretty cool
problem okay
hey this is just a random example where
exactly the same variation works but
it's supposedly not as good because
these pawns just have nothing to do with
the position so you don't add anything
to it right it's the same exact solution
and it still works
the pawns don't affect the solution but
it's not considered by problem is to be
as beautiful now of course this doesn't
really mean much when you're just
thinking about competitive chess but to
the person who's actually making the
problem this all matters and then there
are actually problem competitions where
the problems are rated and that's where
factors like this come into play that
every piece should have some kind of
role so there's a difference even though
problems and studies are useful for your
chest
they also have a world attached to them
that have values that are separated from
chess tournaments and just trying to win
right the most similar thing would be
best game competitions where you do have
that same kind of spirit of just judging
something by on its on its aesthetics
not how it makes you better at chess
yeah a problems cooked well that's a
good question a cooked problem means a
problem that has multiple solutions and
that's also considered very bad so that
means like evil mind should the
Pillsbury game last class
it's like it'd be hard to put that in a
tactics book it should take sage six
because there's Julian pointed out and
they takes f7 - also pretty good so it's
it's like a problem when you have it's a
problem it's a it's not as it's not as
good for publishing when you have these
multiple solutions because it's a bit
frustrating for the reader I'm sure all
of you have experienced this when
looking at old tactic folks or even the
databases on chest tempo and chess calm
and game not that there's sometimes
problems where there are or puzzles
rather they're called puzzles when they
come from real games and problems when
they're composed puzzles there are
puzzles where you know you find a move
that wins a queen and they wanted you to
find another move that wins the plan all
right you've all experienced that right
and so that's another example cooked of
course in the case of puzzles it's not
really a big deal because they're just
really training whereas in a problem
it's considered to be a serious
deficiency but what do we think a lot of
people would have trouble arguing with I
will show you now some of you are gonna
recognize this position unfortunately
those of you who don't I'm sorry those
of you don't are lucky because you never
seen it before yeah like how many people
recognize this position this is just one
of the most I talked about the ready
position being one of the most fantastic
in chests I mean this one is just like
right up there because it there's so few
pieces on the board right to each just
like the ready position
we had one pawn for each side and lone
kings and yet the the magic of the
solution is so surprising so surprising
how many people do recognize this to
this man Holly Julia dies I'm
shonda's yeah okay you all remember I
don't want you to help me with a whole
answer right now
oh sorry this is uh this is like the
bite to move yeah I'll give you the
first move for right because it's not
obvious what's that yeah well it's kind
of weird because I want you to like
solve it for both sides in a way I mean
you to like try to find the draw for
black so black to move and attempt to
draw and then you also I want you to
like basically look at it from both
sides which is of course what you do
when you play a chess game as well and
that's what a lot of people have trouble
with they have a lot more difficulty
finding brilliant moves for their
opponent than they do for themselves
I'd say people are you know probably a
couple hundred points lower rated at
finding brilliance ease for their
opponent just because first of all it's
one move back right so you're already
doing with like one half a move less of
horizon and then on top of that you're
looking at the position from your point
of view all game
well that's cool some of you guys don't
recognize this isn't such a great
position
so this blacks basically trying to draw
all right the queen pawns about the
queen and black wants to draw as we know
Queen versus rook computers might be
able to draw it against uh against a
human who's like you know not like
apparently it's very difficult you have
to be really strong to beat a computer
I've never tried it but computers are
very good at defending or work for a
queen but I mean humans are just always
losing very quickly because it's hard to
get the it's it's it's really weird like
the computer finds like the exact place
to put the rock where you don't have a
check followed by a check winning Iraq
and for for humans is very hard to
defend against the Queen so you can
assume when you get to the end of the
variation what I'm saying is when you
get to the end of the variation and you
have a queen versus a rock you can just
assume you win what's that oh you want
to play work do you to here well the
problem with that is that I'm gonna move
up the board and then I'm gonna stop
like yeah exactly so yeah I'm gonna play
Queen yeah I'm not gonna come to the C
file until until it's like here yeah and
then we have what I was talking about
where you can you can you can hold on
for a little while but eventually you're
gonna lose contact and lose lose contact
with your your king in your rock yeah so
black is a better drawing account that
much better about drawing attempt yeah
we're these six check is certainly a
better drawing attempt and that now
trying to analyze that a little bit on
your own
did you ever seen this Julian okay
you'll probably remember it closer to
the time I'm oh okay you're looking at
it from light yeah well the thing is if
you played Kings e5 and black does have
like a kind of nice resource right if
black leaves work the v6 check and white
plays Kings e5 what will black by.ya
work to D one and now our idea is that
if you Queen we get that score in with
with work c1 so now you're not actually
actually grovel back and get that draw
with king king b6 all right so instead
of work the six check king c5 how do you
play for a win with white of course can
be seven is not good right if work d6
check King b7 what would black play just
work these have an instant draw right
so instead White's attempt to win would
be what tv5 that's right and then what
would black do
got it and then Kim c4 would lead to the
same fate as before all right so instead
why please what this is one that we like
to do in our heads because I worked you
five check and then we're looking at
whites next myth yeah sure I keep going
right you've got a goal here I think
your goal is starting to become a parent
right yeah exactly so after keen before
black plays wide in order to try to keep
doing this rook d4 track got it and then
white plays wide and then work the three
Jack and then one is white play and now
that looks like bad news right because
we can no longer check and we can no
longer go you know we don't have a zero
square to go to work to DZero
I'll be a good move so that if you Queen
we still score you but since I was not
allowed blacks last attempt to draw the
game as well what's black super good
move and this is why you know it's hard
to you have to be able to see your
opponent's good plans as well black has
a really great try here to try to get a
draw and then White has an amazing
counter try so you see you guys
visualize that position right where we
got our work back down on d3 and the
King's gotten gotten to c2 and now what
do we do to try to draw it looks like
the white pawn is going to Queen or just
going to be left with a rook versus a
queen and we're gonna lose so do we have
any any kind of saving tries here rook
d4 okay let's see if somebody else can
see the point of that now if white were
to make a queen what does black do
exactly very good so let's uh let's see
so instead what's the hole there
what can white do inside I'll go over
this on the board in a second too but I
just want everybody to try to visualize
because this is the advanced class and
visualizing eight moves ahead is in such
an empty position where there's not very
much going on should be doable
oh cool yeah yeah yeah this is yeah I
mean this is just an amazing position
and to see it's incredible that it
exists with so few pieces on the board
just uh any of this is just crazy
you guys know what you guys see what the
a solution is for writing in that
position so after work t4 White has a
super move superb move there you go
right exactly
so let's take a look at that on the
board so this is all for us and then the
rookie for brilliant try so that if
Queen rook c4 creates a stalemate and
now you make our little rook and we are
threatening checkmate
well meet in two so blacks only defense
work to a four and then the coup de Gras
can be three and that's another double
attack we've seen a lot of it's funny
you like I talked about how the ready
position is in essence a double
attacking position this is also a very
cool finale double attack where the
White King is attacking the rook on a
four and we're also threatening
checkmate so you're having to give up
the rock or get made it BAM yeah I know
this is a really a crazy position I
think this one's even better than the
ready position it's got to be one of the
pool is coolest like position with just
two pieces on the board crazy so the
beauty of simplicity are really just in
fantastic and it's nice that you get to
see another piece on the board as well
I'm great position let's look at this
one this one is a little harder wait to
move and win yes
so as you'll see we talked earlier about
a distraction in the other class so so
if works you to basically your idea that
if you're trying to distract me from the
you're trying to distract me from the
the d8 square right so that's your idea
but the problem is the end of that
variation after Bishop da check g5 now
the pawn on g2 is pinned otherwise would
just be made on what is that that is
that the end of the story over here I'll
make you guys figure it out from here
you guys have this book that's a great
book I mean it's mostly just regular end
games but there's plenty of studies
sprinkled in
that's the Dover etske in game annual
most of Dover it skis books are really
like quite difficult but this one like
there's really a lot for everybody I
mean like some of his books are really I
think they're geared for like 2400 class
literally yeah I mean not I mean this
one though this one like there was
really like there's the he goes through
a lot of stuff and he's even got
sections where he talks about there he's
got sections where he talks about things
in there outlined in blue and that's
like a really really essential stuff and
then he goes over like the more advanced
permutations after the text in blue kind
of similar to what you know Jeremy
Suleman has an endgame book as well
which does something similar which kind
of splits it up by rating I don't know
if anybody had that book that's also
really cool you have that one yeah that
was your first check chess book
and reassess her chess is really good -
yeah so
this is what we call a domination study
there was a famous composer Kaspar Eon
who I think one of your other teachers
frequent teachers Grandmaster version of
Cobian is a huge fan of Gaspar Ian an
Armenian hero who made plenty of
beautiful Indian compositions he has a
book full of them how many are in that
like thousands right yeah so actually
work of c2 was correct and after Queen
takes c2 we just need to find the the
right move now after Bishop do you a
check g5
well Bishop she's having the Queen can
capture well you go you're on the right
path
the right path not Bishop e7 you
actually have a move which threaded in
something directly even in studies that
can be good well yes because Bishop a5
threatens me right we're made into so
black actually must stop it well you
could play queen up to the other way to
stop it would be but g4 but that would
lead to want it then Bishop d8 is just
me right so you have to you have to use
the Queen to protect you one square Wow
making sure not to allow g3 right so you
only got two options so let's say Queen
e2 and now I
now Bishop c7 yeah because if you play
Bishop you one then Queen takes you want
allows g3 right so now again if g4 what
happens
hmm yeah exactly so so what what does
black have to do here
what's blocks only move really they keep
things line
yeah Queen f2 and now know what does
what I do
they should be made
so if Bishop d6 now
now we can blind Dale so basically if he
moves the Queen along on this and this
file
I'm sorry rag if he moves the Queen on
the rank Bishop g3 is made if he moves
the Queen away from the rank g3 has made
so it's just like incredible position
right or blacks basically in zigs Wang
and this Bishop is actually stronger
than the point unit but black still has
a better defensive try then just just
get he made it what is best
what's his best little defensive try
here yes Queen that for Jack that's what
you meant right and now now what okay I
know you better not take here after all
that work after all that brilliant work
you better play the right move here
eukaryote first yeah that's a pretty
cool position alright yeah and we should
get the final position on the board very
nice very nice so speaking of kooks
let's talk briefly about what would
happen what was the other suggestion I
think after in this position we talked
about Bishop b8 quickly exactly and now
there's no Bishop d8 mating so it's
never as good
well yeah I mean you don't really have a
lot of other moves you owe your because
this one because this one BB your other
try but there's also jtpharr yeah so
same thing yeah and again obviously
makes a problem superior yeah very cool
one I've got some other some other good
ones well last time I showed I showed
how like we were all looking at simple
positions and it's a bit of a thing
where people are always talking about
how in chess problems and studies a lot
of people like to like the ones that are
simpler like the Saavedra problem which
is there were crimp on one and the ready
problem it's very aesthetic to chess
players because you see the pure power
of a piece but there's also something to
be said for like they're really crazy
ones like the maiden one we looked at
last class and of course there are some
pretty wild fashions across the street
as well like this a really incredible
installation by Hibiki which is on the
first floor or it's like wow somebody
can wear that that is this is an
installation in across the street at the
world chess Hall of Fame it's one of the
archetypes of the Queen this is the
Explorer and basically rr9 like mini art
installations to represent all the
different archetypes of the Queen it's
just absolutely incredible I mean it's
really just even if you don't like
normally art in fashion it's very very
much worth a look just by the famous
composer Sam Lloyd
yeah and this one I also wanted to show
because it's like it's in this it's in
this crazy shape awesome all right you
said you wanted to make the position in
a shape and he had a really great quote
about this position actually I found
this in one of my I put this over here
actually I read off my phone yeah
it's actually wait to play on black to
play so there's a there's a winning move
for both sides yeah and what do you said
really reminded me because you know last
time I was talking about how in chess
problems are is either like the problem
which is really really weird-looking
which ends up looking kind of simple
when you get the answer and then there's
also the really really simple looking
problem which ends up being super deep
and complicated when you get the answer
and if you think about that that's a lot
of what the two extremes of beauty are
in other fields - right like something
extremely minimalistic which is a lot
deeper or something which is really
crazy and clashing but somehow
everything works
despite that right so we see that in a
lot of different fields let me try to
pull up that quote okay this problem by
Lloyd is called a wheel within a wheel
because as you see there's a wheel and
then there's another wheel and it's
white - might move and made into black
moving made into and Lloyd said about
the problem that he was attempting to
show the most absurd position he could
think of fettered by the conditions of
producing four problems in the one
diagram there are also self mates which
we're not gonna get into although I do
sometimes try to sometimes it's fun to
have people try to figure out the worst
move
okay what's white me yeah sure
excellent that's right and then after
King takes very good it's a really weird
looking mate right cool
nice and I think I have the the black
one loaded separately looks exactly the
same
so what's the answer and that after can
you form
that's what I what happens here rook
takes Bishop yeah I have to the white
one's better than the black one in this
in this case right I mean the the the
black one but it's just amazing that it
can work for both sides and that's crazy
position and can you imagine somebody
just decided to wake up one morning and
and make a position of a wheel between
behind a wheel with a maiden want with a
made into a made into and two cellmates
that's insane what a genius right pretty
cool yeah that's why I like this is
white to move in when someone's like
this one I was thinking about joining
the last class it's not the hardest one
but it's just really cool let's give
everybody a minute okay this one again
because it's very simple so that's why I
like this one I mean it's simple it's
not that easy to see but it's so
simplified there's so few pieces on the
board
a miniature as they call it and chess
competitive chess we call in miniature a
game that ends very quickly yeah is that
is it 25 moves okay and then in problem
is it's ones with a fewer than 5 pieces
right fewer than 7 ok 7 including Kings
oh that says so is five five pieces
other than the King yeah okay
it is Bishop 87 and then and then once
you're anybody got a full you got a full
variation for me at Bishop a 7 what do
you think black plays Bishop c3 then
what would you buy
and then after Bishop a1 not King b3
because any four check and we covering
the diagonal again
so Bishop 87 where are we now beat today
seven bishops III King c2 Bishop I want
right that's where you guys are
Oh
again King DD 3 was suggested but then e
4 check stops starting Riya allows the
bishop to to guard that diagonal reopens
yeah not Bishop c5 again we were here to
play for
yeah but I'm guarding a whole diagonal
now and I'm gonna get my King back in
yeah I think somebody called it out or
they are actually probably just didn't
see the finale
no again we got the e4 coming in we're
at Bishop Bishop e7 so you obviously
can't take is NH 7 NH 8 equals Queen so
you play Bishop c3 King c2 Bishop a 1
and now it's white tomato put it on the
board I thought it'll be easier see you
see it as soon as I put the pieces on
the board good job and now if pawn takes
d4 what happens nice and then we're just
playing Queen in well fish of d4 is not
the same because if h7 e for alright so
if Bishop d4 we play what team b3
exactly very good and now if we play
what's that
if efore check now instead of taking on
e4 we have King takes bishop right
and now if King G v h7
and after king g6 queen efore check we
have King takes t4 again right yeah
that's a little cool problem yeah so
simple one more really nice yeah so you
really see the total diversity here and
just problems the very simple problem
miniature as we call it with five majors
with five rather five pieces whether
prawns or four major pieces or minor
pieces and two kings from just basically
an infinite number of pieces you don't
even know where they came from
five LightSquared Bishop Saul that so
the absolute polar opposites but both
really train the same exact skills
getting better at calculating
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]